Let's see who else wants to get
on today. Why don't we go to.
There's just so many people. Let's go to Casey
from Oklahoma City, Casey from Oklahoma City.
What's going on?
Casey, I know you're unmuted
because I heard a gonk in the background,
but you were on Casey from Oklahoma City.
Can you hear me OK? Yeah, I sort of can.
Sorry, I'm in office. Look at the mosque on
Walk down the hall. Yeah. So my question
is kind of a hypothetical and then your
opinion on the matter.
I generally feel like
both parties should not pack the court.
This is a conversation that's happening
right now with with Berrett. And,
you know, I kind of feel like
the Democrats could say, yeah, we're
going to pack the court with two.
We're gonna to we're just going
to even the nomination you made.
And then we're going to add one more for
the one that we we wanted. But I still
don't think it's the right thing to do. I'm
just curious what your thoughts are on it.
Casey, are you using power
tools while you talk to me?
I am in a manufacturing plant.
So they are literally power
tools. OK. That's good. I'm glad I'm not
going crazy. So listen, here's the thing.
I don't think Joe Biden wants to pack the court.
I think Joe Biden has actually been pretty clear
in the past that it's not something he wants to
do. I don't think Joe Biden is going to do it.
So while I understand the criticism that he's not
being upfront about whether he would or wouldn't,
your idea of adding to it, I just don't
think it's something Joe Biden wants to
do. And he's trying to keep the threat of
packing the court to have some leverage. I
don't know that it's working. Barrett
could be confirmed before we know it,
but your idea is an interesting one. I just
don't think Joe Biden has any interest in it.
Well, and I don't think. I don't think we
should. I mean, I like the idea that the
courts are independent, but I don't know
how they also can be as we're all human.
So, I mean, you also are picking judges based
on their opinion, something like the ATF course.
So it's a weird argument because they
say, well, certainly political. But
you're obviously rushing this through before they
see the case. When? November 10th. I think it is.
Get it. If if if judges merely interpreted the
law in a robotic way and spat out a response,
you would have robots do it. You wouldn't be you
wouldn't put people in there and your correctly
pointing out that, of course, their politics
matter. There's no question about it. And,
you know, playing these games that they
play during confirmation hearings about.
No, I would simply look at the law and come
out with the right answer. I'm just a I just
reflect what the law is. I don't come up with
anything. Of course, that's not the way it works.
Right, the bat that was on top
of my head. The second call, and
this is the best.
All right, Casey,
I'll let you get back to the manufacturing
there. A very, very much appreciated.